[Musik]
ja ich sagen immer ich bin eigentlich
keine freunde als er als mann hat mir
viel los und sicherlich die einzig frei
wohne ich immer gewisse sind so noch
kommen
das ist bisher relativ gut ist es klasse
a bissle eine erotische beziehung
sie schreit worte vom bruder gerold
münchen kloster einsiedeln etwas salopp
gesagt der mann der der madonna an die
wäsche darf ihn umweht eine mixtur aus
weihrauch schmelzenden kerzenwachs um
frischen blumen wie daraus eine
spezielle erotik für pilger und münchen
steht davon handelt dieser film
die besten angezogene alarm atomen keine
so viele und so kostbare kreide besitzen
wie die schwarze madonna in barocken
einsiedeln in der nacht wird sie
ausgezogen
allerdings nicht bis zum letzten und
rock der ist sowieso ins holz geschnitzt
bruder gerrit der sakristan laut das
fenster komplett stets der gleiche
ablauf der und bekommt einen
vorgeschmack auf die ewigkeit
es ist morgens um sechs seine uhr zeigt
zwar erst fünf doch der große bruder
weigert sich auf sommerzeit umzustellen
er wolle sich dem diktat aus brüssel
nicht unterwerfen zeit sei etwas
gottgegebenes die erste die zur kapelle
drängt ist eine inderin globalisierung
der madonna nimmt das bruder gerd einer
barocken orte der schweiz einsiedeln
oder wie man in alten zeiten sagte das
kloster im finsteren wald als seine
schulkameraden in out of beatles hörten
machte sich große sony bald auf den weg
ins kloster
ich hab ihn zu achten kann ich oft da
lege ich vor ungefähr als tagebuch hoffe
ich liebe und das nicht immer nur hier
und da ist die erste erinnerung
einsiedler die familie demian itsax.de
steuer überhaupt wohl boxee um die erste
fahrt mit dem liebe fahrzeug ist
offensichtlich sie und offenbar hätte
mich damals sehr fasziniert dich
luftstrom die haben nicht da ich endlich
alt und wie es
festhalten re zeichnet das ganz tagebuch
ich voller erinnerungen an meine
kindheit zum beispiel auf die gesichter
start der lehrer sagte mir beim ade
sagen ich kenne in den himmel
und da habe ich das himmelstor zeichnet
und warum er den himmel
da müssen meine zähne frage will ich bin
ich halt mich lieb ist sie für sind für
die damalige zeit ich bin ich immer brav
sicher wenn ich mich eigentlich nicht
viel streich gemachter des dritten
minute brauchen immer gute frage ich
hoffe es nicht hoffen alle andere als
ich wieder im himmelbett xii weil es so
schön will das haben wir nicht sagt ich
glaube es der himmel ist wo diese nie
verstehen mechanismen nicht ausreichend
um das einen 18 finde
noch ist das ein reich die sakristei ihr
hat er die kostbaren gewänder den
schmuck und so etwas wie seine
persönlichen devotionalien die
avantgarde prominente zu erinnern
besucher tv-empfang paulo coelho play
ernesto cardenal fredi m ude bernard
thurnheer peter alexander solschenizyn
wird schneider senior wollte
ingrid noll abtprimas notker wolf
leonardo nigro haustier haben zwei der
roger federer
hans günther meyer fürstin gloria von
thurn und taxis
richard von weizsäcker sf lotte adolf
ogi kanäle hans erni wo es laut peter
lenz hat chromatin suchte peter scholl
latour und switches gegenstandslos witte
und da war doch noch was mit giacomo
casanova gerät ja sogar weltruf der
einsiedler der frau erhält ja das haben
wir nachlassen im sinne biografie des so
angetan sie vor monaten hat sich kann
ich nicht sagt jedenfalls hat ihm das
ganze ambiente hier sehr entsprochen
er bietet bislang abt ist nach art
widerruft serie und hat eigentlich die
verständnislos hatte
nur hat das problem in zürich vor sieben
verschiedene abstieg der kutsche
vorgefahren
mit der sehr hübsche solothurn und das
sind die kloster plan wieder begraben
auch bruder gerold lässig verführen
allerdings nicht durch dieselben
rundungen wie es einem casanova passiert
ihm haben es die reize die die
stiftsbibliothek versprüht angetan dass
es sich hier tun kann wann und wie er
wolle
entschädigung für vieles auf das einem
kloster verzichten müsse familie geld
und persönliche güter wie bibliophilen
schätze hineinzieht und sind legende
gerd genießt das privileg des größter
liche bücher booms dass ich die fivb an
die illustrierte buch von salvador dalí
ich zeige dass gar nicht suchen und
suchen durch jahrzehnte 46 geschlossen
stand ein tablett wenn nicht alles algen
aber eigentlich nur zwei wochen zeit zum
bau von bomben als rezensent ließ krimi
und dass ich nicht mehr erster linie vom
mensch erwartet und ich war schlecht
wisse der waage das eigentlich ingrid
noll zeit dass ich eigentlich von der
bekannteste deutsche krimi autorinnen
wissen sie was sie mir geantwortet hat
auch gehen sie mir das ganze alte
testament ist ein einziger krimi sie
tempel und sieht eigentlich recht will
die stadt sache ziemlich brutal was im
alten testament alles erzählt wird
vertrauen zurück ich habe nicht ein
factum freiheit aber eher dass wir
irgendwie ja das sogar heilige schrift
der haut so handliche vorkamen
das ist irgendwie linie rechtfertigung
von elektro krimi der ordensgründer der
heilige benedikt hat bildung der mönche
groß geschrieben so war einsiedeln ein
zentrum der buchherstellung und bis zu
seinem eintritt ins kloster arbeitete
geld denn auch aussetzer über den
estrich gelangt man in einen trakt mit
vielen leerstehenden mönchszellen ihr
freund gerold seiner zweiten
leidenschaft alles was irgendwie mit
wilhelm tell zu tun hat hat der patriot
zusammengetragen
als schulbub durfte guten walter little
spielen sei dieses zeit wohnen zwei
seelen in seiner brust eine der
schwarzen madonna eine des wilhelm tell
es geht da lang oder es gibt ja das
beispiel es gibt frische eier aus dem
burgenland selbstverständlich mit dem
willen traum im wald oder es gibt ein
bier das jetzt wirklich zur sache da die
zwei morde und das da ihnen hat alles
mitteilte das geht nur als teil von der
sammlung sind literarische belegstelle
1200 jahre steht das kloster
früher lebten die mönche von applus
heute von spenden einsiedeln war
schauplatz von pilger strömen und von
religiösen wären fünfmal wurde das große
abgefackelt die zwei jungen an der
spitze täuschen über das größte problem
im kloster hinweg der nachwuchs jeden
abend ziehen die verbliebenen mönche zur
madonna salve regina
sei gegrüßt königin der barmherzigkeit
singen die alten mönche
[Musik]
geduld ist laienbruder er arbeitet in
der sakristei im küchendienst und aus
krankenpflege für seine alten mitbrüder
60 mönche leben noch in einsiedeln platz
hätte es für vier mal so viele wie
genoni als junger mann hier einfahrt
waren es noch über 100 prügel um hartes
seit der siegener weniger mönche gibt
sind auch externe haushaltshilfen
eingestellt wurden sogar frauen einige
alte mönche liegen in der krankenstation
die ist in der klausur des klosters
dorthin muss die wäsche für
außenstehende ist das sperrzonen als
auch für unsere kamera
lukas mit auf seine velotour
ab und zu eine freie stunde und pro jahr
14 tage ferien hat jeder mensch so gut
berühmt ist das kloster einsiedeln auch
für seine pferdezucht
wie keine bunten genießen die zwei
gestandenen männer den freien nachmittag
geht über kommt ein heiliger ehrgeiz der
sakristan bringt lukas der musikus des
trostes arche in strammer
fast das ganze leben hinter mauern
alles was sie verdienten lieferten sie
dem kloster ab alles was sie zum leben
brauchten dafür sorgte das kloster
sehr gut das fleisch fell schlösser
burgen tvi sind unsere beiden mönche in
den kurzen hosen stecken geblieben auch
wenn sie schon bald wieder in ihren
schwarzen kutten daherkommen
ora et labora lautet die klosterregion
bete und arbeite route geld steigt hinab
in die sakristei auf ihn wartet eine
besondere mission in sachen schwarzen
madonna doch zuerst zur leidenschaft von
pater lucassen der priester mönche
arbeitet im klostereigenen gymnasium als
lehrer seit der pensioniert ist kann er
seine großen liebe früh im orgelspiel
zurzeit ist es ein stück von charles
marie widors toccata
jetzt muss ich aber noch registrieren
der organist wäre es mit diesem stück
zur perfektion bringen erhöht seit tagen
und oftmals in der nacht wenn er wach in
seiner zelle liegt um dem geiste die
partitur durchgeht springt er als
instrument zum flug ja
pater lucas meint er könne nicht so
hinter quer warum er im kloster gelandet
sein
wie frei sein leben aber sei das können
uns in seiner liebsten sprache sagen
'bitte musik
das barocke einsiedeln bietet raum für
verschiedene musikrichtungen
französische euro gregorianischer gesang
musik und später in diesem film
afrikanischer traum werbung
meine damen und herren ich darf sie ganz
herzlich begrüßen spirituelle modeschau
ein besonderes wort unser modell wenn
man so sagen darf ist eigentlich die
einsiedler muttergottes die schwarze
madonna von einsiedeln die wir hier in
einem bild abgebildet sehen
bezeichnenderweise hier ohne behang habe
hier auch keine fahrräder mitgenommen wo
man das gnadenbild ohne behang sieht das
heißt im prinzip könnte man unser
gnadenbild so aufstellen auch zur
verehrung für die gläubigen die herkunft
der marienstatue ist unbekannt von 500
jahren so sie nach einziehen und
gekommen sein
das ist thema sie hat zwei kleider für
unser kloster gestiftet und das hast du
als erstes gemacht dieses blaue gewandt
hat sie immer gestiftet die
modeschöpferin und ihre tochter lebt
seit 20 jahren als flüchtlinge in zürich
der krieg hat sie aus deren vertrieben
ich denke man da sagen du bist muslimin
ja und das ist vielleicht doch ich sehe
ja eben
wir glauben das ist auch globalisierung
spirituelle jaja über das geschenk der
muslimin mussten die mönche zuerst
abstimmen
das ist dass engel ein kleid von 1686
violette atlas mit zahlreicher gold
stickerei und gold platten der älteste
noch vorhandene behang und sehr kostbar
unter 30 gewändern kann bruder gehe
unter auswählen je nach riedrode
wechselt die farbe barock im
landläufigen sinn sind sie alle immer
donnern figur ist aus edlem lindenholz
aber ihre anziehungskraft muss magie
sein
denn die schwarze madonna wird auch von
solchen verehrt die mit der kirche
nichts am hut haben
[Musik]
auf der kinderzeichnung ist die madonna
weiß aber warum ist sie eigentlich
schwarz die kirche sagt vom vielen
kerzen russ aber die feministinnen sagen
die schwarze frau seine vorchristliche
gottheit schwarz wie die erde aus der
alles leben kommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die exotischen opfergaben der
afrikanischen wallfahrer finde bruder
gerold in den nächsten tagen dann in
welchem es nie wieder gern als rasender
reporter
er arbeitet auch als journalist für den
einsiedler raum zeigen und die kloster
eigene zeitschrift soll
[Applaus]
[Musik]
l
[Applaus]
die katholische kirche habe in unseren
breitengraden viele von ihrer
mütterlichkeit verloren
klagen manche vielleicht der quer dass
die anziehungskraft der schwarzen
madonna
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die geben
[Musik]
grossbeeren gewänder liegen im
luftschutzkeller etwa alle zwei wochen
hat gute geld nachtschicht dann wenn
wieder den wechsel bei der schwarzen
madonna ansteht erhält konkurrenz in
form von
profan geräuschen der putzteufel hat
auch ein
heute wird die schwarze madonna ins
blaue muslimische gewand gehüllt favorit
bei den pilgern
[Musik]
das kloster einsiedeln kennt kaum
grenzen
bitter für frömmigkeit noch leidenschaft
noch spricht ergebenheit
[Musik]
der sieg sei die an der interseroh durch
eine besondere frau monika schmidt auch
als mensch
[Musik]
nicht kramer ja ja ja